Tom are you there?
汤姆，你在那儿吗？
Yeah
在。
Ray, are you there?
雷，你在那儿吗？
Yes, indeed.
在，确实在。
OK. So repeat after me, from WBEZ Chicago.
好的。跟着我重复一遍，来自芝加哥WBEZ电台。
From WBEZ Chicago.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台。
And Public Radio International.
以及国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life .
这是《美国生活》节目。
We'll do that in unison.
我们要齐声说。
OK.
好的。
It's This American Life.
这是《美国生活》。
What pros you are.
你们真是专业人士。
OK, here's the set up. In a studio in Boston, the host of NPR's Car Talk , Tom and Ray Maggliozi, experts in car repair and owners of their own car repair garage in Cambridge. In the This American Life studio in Chicago, me. And in a studio in New York City, a former employee of the Car Guys radio show, Joe Richman. Who once turned to these national experts for help with his own car.
好了，背景是这样的。在波士顿的一间演播室里，有NPR《汽车谈话》节目的主持人汤姆和雷·马格里奥齐，他们是汽车维修专家，在剑桥拥有自己的修车行。在芝加哥的《美国生活》演播室里，有我。而在纽约的一间演播室里，有一位《汽车谈话》广播节目的前员工乔·里奇曼。他曾经向这些国家级专家寻求帮助，处理他自己的车。
But as we all know, sometimes the experts screw up.
但正如我们所知，有时专家也会搞砸。
Joe, what was your exact job at Car Talk ?
乔，你在《汽车谈话》的具体工作是什么？
I edited the show. They would do the show live in Boston, and then I would kind of package it for the national show.
我负责剪辑节目。他们在波士顿现场录制节目，然后我将其包装成全国性播出的节目。
I do remember-- I have this image of you, Joe, sitting there on the other side of the glass, looking very studied. Like you were concentrating on the parts that you have to cut out. Making mental notes as you went along. That won't do. No, that's going to have to go too.
我记得——我脑海里有你坐在玻璃另一边的影像，乔，看起来非常专注。就像你在集中精力思考那些必须剪掉的部分。边听边做心理笔记。那个不行。不，那个也得剪掉。
When I was living in Boston I had this '72 Plymouth Valiant. Slant-6 engine. It was red with a black top.
我住在波士顿的时候，有一辆72年的普利茅斯勇士（Plymouth Valiant）。斜置6缸发动机。红色车身，黑色车顶。
Now, Joe, your mother had a special feeling about this particular car.
乔，你母亲对这辆特定的车有一种特别的感觉。
Well. OK. I guess the thing was, my mom kept saying that I wasn't going to find a girlfriend until I got rid of the car. I'm not sure. I think she felt that there was a little too much obsession with the car. The car was just too big a part of my life.
嗯，好吧。我想情况是这样的，我妈妈一直说，除非我把车卖掉，否则我找不到女朋友。我不确定。我觉得她觉得我对这辆车太着迷了。这辆车在我生命中占据的比例太大了。
Now, what does that mean, too big a part of your life? You were spending too much time thinking about the car? Loving the car? Fixing  the car?
那么，这到底意味着什么，在你生命中占比太大？你花太多时间在想车的事了吗？爱车？修车？
At this point I didn't have a lot of friends. I drove the car around a lot. I paid attention to the car. was kind of-- I wrote a song about the car. It was that kind of a thing.
那时我没多少朋友。我经常开车到处转。我很关注这辆车。我甚至——我为这辆车写了一首歌。就是那种程度。
Wait, you wrote a song about the car?
等等，你为这辆车写了一首歌？
Yeah, I wrote a song about it. I actually, I looked for the lyrics.
是的，我写了。我其实找过歌词。
Well, can we hear it?
那我们能听听吗？
I looked for the lyrics, I couldn't find them.
我找过歌词，但我找不到。
Oh, you're a liar. You're a liar.
哦，你是个骗子。你是个骗子。
I'm not lying. I loved the car.
我没撒谎。我爱那辆车。
Joe, do you remember any of the song at all?
乔，你还记得这首歌的任何部分吗？
You must remember the chorus.
你一定记得副歌吧。
Yeah. Give us a line or two. You don't have to sing it, maybe you could just recite the words.
对。给我们来一两句。不用唱出来，也许你直接朗诵歌词也行。
Come on. You can't leave us like this.
拜托。你不能把我们晾在这儿。
Basically, the song was sort of about this issue. Can I have a girlfriend if I've got the car?
基本上，这首歌讲的就是这个问题。如果我有这辆车，我还能有女朋友吗？
Ah.
啊。
In fact, I know from talking to Joe that at the time, Tom and Ray knew what Joe's mother thought about this, and agreed with her. As long as he had the car, he would never get a girl. And then, the car started to have big troubles.
事实上，我从乔那里得知，当时汤姆和雷知道乔的母亲是怎么想的，而且也同意她的观点。只要他还留着那辆车，他就永远交不到女朋友。然后，那辆车就开始出大毛病了。
Just to let you  know what time period this was, everyone has started to call it the Plymouth Valdez. That's around the time--
让你知道那是哪个时期，大家开始叫它“普利茅斯瓦尔迪兹号”。大约就在那时候——
Around 1989, 1990.
大约在1989年、1990年左右。
Thank you. Well, I asked Ray about the car. And I said, you know, it was burning a lot of oil. And basically he said, we'll do a ring job. I don't know if we can fix it. And it was that kind of thing where, you know, am I throwing money away? Should I just put money into a new car? But, of course, you don't do that when you have a '72 Plymouth Valiant, right? So I decided to take a chance.
谢谢。嗯，我问过雷关于那辆车的事。我说，你知道，它烧了很多机油。基本上他说，我们换下活塞环试试吧。我不知道能不能修好。就是那种情况，你知道，我是不是在浪费钱？我应该直接把钱投在一辆新车上吗？但当然，当你拥有一辆72年的普利茅斯勇士时，你不会那么做，对吧？所以我决定碰碰运气。
So anyway I got the car back and that-- I guess that was about-- Ray, what would you-- was that about $600 back then would you say? Not only-- it didn't really fix the problem and, in fact, that kind of initiated the steep decline of the car where it kind of never recovered.
总之我把车拿了回来，那——我想大约是——雷，你会怎么说——那时大约花了600美元吧？不仅——那并没有真正解决问题，事实上，那反而导致了这辆车的急剧衰落，再也没能恢复过来。
Oh, that was the beginning of the end.
哦，那是末日的开始。
It was the beginning of the end.
那是末日的开始。
We did a valve job. And I am sure I warned you in advance that it might not work.
我们做了气门维修。而且我敢肯定我事先警告过你可能没用。
You did. You said, this might not do it. And you could be throwing your money away. And that's what--
你是说过。你说，这可能没用。而且你可能是在浪费钱。那正是——
Not really throwing it away. You were giving it to my brother.
不算浪费。你那是把它给了我兄弟。
And my kids were in college at the time, and these things happen. Let's just call it a cash transfer.
当时我的孩子们在上大学，这种事总会发生。我们把它称为现金转移吧。
So Ray sent this car spiraling toward its grave. It only took a few weeks, Joe says. It's like the car slowly dissolved into dust. Like a vampire stake through the heart. And, just a few weeks after the car died, Joe started dating. And if you ask Ray today if he killed Joe's car intentionally, knowing that Joe would end up with a girlfriend if he did that, Ray will only say that that is something that he is certainly capable of doing.
所以雷让这辆车飞速驶向坟墓。乔说，只花了几个星期。就像这辆车慢慢溶成了灰尘。就像吸血鬼心脏上的木桩。就在车坏掉几周后，乔开始约会了。如果你今天问雷他是否故意弄坏乔的车，好让他能交到女朋友，雷只会说这是他确实有能力做到的事。
Which is the way it goes when you go to an expert. Sometimes they will ignore what you want, and do whatever they want to do. And then sometimes they just fail. Maybe that's what happened.
去找专家时就是这样。有时他们会无视你的需求，只做他们想做的事。有时他们只是单纯地失败了。也许这就是发生的事情。
Ray says that when you go to a mechanic, the chances that they will give you solid, honest advice, real advice, and not try to rip you off, and not accidentally screw things up in some way, he says the odds of that are actually pretty bad.
雷说，当你去找机械师时，他们给你提供扎实、诚实的建议，不试图坑你，或者不意外地弄坏东西的可能性，实际上相当低。
Oh I think you're way below 50% in that regard. No seriously. I think even well-intentioned mechanics are going to give you the wrong advice half the time.
哦，我认为在这方面远低于50%。不，说真的。我认为即使是初衷良好的机械师，有一半时间也会给你错误的建议。
Gee, I don't think it's like that.
哎呀，我不觉得会那样。
I would think more by accident than by mal intent.
我觉得更多是出于意外，而不是恶意。
I would guess way higher than that.
我猜概率要高得多。
You haven't been around the shop much lately.
你最近没怎么去修车行吧。
Experts give bad advice all the time. And so we devote our radio program today to stories of people getting terrible advice from specialists who supposedly know better. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in two acts. Act One, "An Epidemic Created by Doctors." In that act, the story of how thousands of people went to psychotherapists who, with the best of intentions, administered a kind of therapy that just made these people worse, not better. Act Two, "Not Stella Adler, just Stellllaaah." In that act, a glimpse of Marlon Brando's series of instructional videos about acting called Lying for a Living. They have yet to be released, we get a sneak preview. Does being a great actor make you a great acting teacher?
专家一直给出糟糕的建议。因此，我们今天的广播节目专门探讨人们从自以为是的专业人士那里获得糟糕建议的故事。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为两幕。第一幕，“医生制造的流行病”。在这一幕中，讲述了成千上万的人去找心理治疗师，后者出于好心，却实施了一种只会让这些人病情恶化而不是好转的疗法。第二幕，“不是斯特拉·阿德勒，只是斯——特——拉”。在这一幕中，我们一窥马龙·白兰度名为《以谎言为生》的系列表演教学视频。它们尚未发布，我们先睹为快。成为伟大的演员能让你成为伟大的表演老师吗？
I bet if you had guessed the answer to that question right now, you would guess right. But stay with us.
我打赌如果你现在猜这个问题的答案，你一定能猜对。但请留下来听节目。
Act one, "An Epidemic Created by Doctors." In the early 1990s, people across America turned to experts in psychology for help. And many people were told that the source of their problems could be traced to traumatic events that they could not even remember. To memories that had to be recovered through special techniques. This was the recovered memory movement.
第一幕，“医生制造的流行病”。20世纪90年代初，全美的民众转向心理学专家寻求帮助。许多人被告知，他们问题的根源可以追溯到他们甚至不记得的创伤性事件。这些记忆必须通过特殊技术恢复。这就是“恢复记忆运动”。
These days, this whole approach to psychology has fallen out of favor. There were a series of well-publicized cases, and multimillion dollar lawsuits against therapists by patients who had been led to remember instances of child abuse and satanic worship that simply never had occurred. At this point, the American Psychological Association and the American Psychiatric Association have both concluded that buried memories like this are rare. And treatment to recover these memories should be viewed with skepticism.
这些天来，这种心理学方法已不再流行。发生了一系列广为人知的案例，以及患者针对治疗师提起的数百万美元诉讼，这些患者被引导去回忆根本从未发生过的虐童和崇拜撒旦的事件。目前，美国心理学会和美国精神医学学会都得出结论，这种被掩埋的记忆是罕见的。恢复这些记忆的治疗应该受到怀疑。
Testimony based on recovered memories is now difficult to enter in court cases. Malpractice insurance often doesn't protect therapists if they do this kind of therapy. And, in retrospect, it feels like therapists accidentally unleashed a kind of epidemic. Doing people more harm than good.
基于恢复记忆的证词现在很难进入法庭案件。如果治疗师进行这种治疗，医疗事故保险通常不会保护他们。回顾过去，感觉就像治疗师无意中引发了一种流行病。对人造成的伤害大于好处。
So what happened? That so many experts came to believe in a treatment that turned out to make so many other patients worse? And what happened when the patients and the therapists figured it all out? Alix Spiegel put together this story.
那么发生了什么？为什么这么多专家会相信一种最终让这么多患者情况恶化的治疗方法？当患者和治疗师弄清这一切时，又发生了什么？艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔整理了这个故事。
A warning to listeners with small children that it mentions sex and child abuse. Alix's story begins with one patient, and a simple question. How did it happen? In a simple, practical way, how could an expert lead a patient to believe all sorts of horrible things about his or her own life which never happened at all?
提醒有小孩的听众，内容涉及性和虐待儿童。艾丽克斯的故事从一位患者和一个简单的问题开始。这是怎么发生的？以一种简单、实际的方式，专家怎么能引导患者相信关于他或她自己生活中发生的各种从未发生过的可怕事情？
Here's how it happened to Beth Rutherford. She was 19. A student nurse working on a cancer ward. Surrounded by men who bled through every opening on their bodies. By old women who died alone in the middle of the night. She found herself struggling with depression. This feeling that life was somehow thin and flat.
这就是贝丝·卢瑟福身上的遭遇。她19岁。是一名在癌症病房工作的实习护士。身边环绕着身体每一个孔洞都在流血的男人。还有在午夜孤独死去的孤寡老人。她发现自己陷入了抑郁。感觉生活某种程度上既单薄又平淡。
Her parents were concerned. They suggested that she talk to a therapist. There was one at their church they thought might be good. Beth's father actually made the call.
她的父母很担心。他们建议她去咨询一位治疗师。他们教会里有一位他们认为可能不错的治疗师。贝丝的父亲亲自打了这个电话。
This first visit was productive. The woman allowed Beth to talk about her experiences in a way that made Beth feel better. She seemed kind, sensible. Beth emerged after an hour feeling calmer, but was told to schedule a follow-up appointment, just to be safe.
第一次访问很有成效。这位女性允许贝丝以一种让贝丝感觉更好的方式谈论她的经历。她看起来既和蔼又理智。贝丝在一小时后带着平静的感觉离开，但被告知为了安全起见，要预约下一次会面。
Four weeks later, when Beth returned, she was doing fine. In fact, she was doing so well that after half an hour she actually ran out of cancer ward material.
四周后，当贝丝回来时，她做得很好。事实上，她做得太好了，以至于半小时后，她就把癌症病房的情况讲完了。
And then, it's kind of like we had nothing left to talk about. But we had some time left over on my appointment time with her. So she asked me, is there anything else that you want to talk about? And I said, no, no. That's kind of it. I can't think of anything. And so she said, well, you know are you sure? This is kind of your time. So if you can think of something.
然后，感觉就像我们没什么可谈的了。但我的预约时间还剩下一些。所以她问我，还有什么你想谈的吗？我说，没有了，没有了。大概就这样。我想不出什么了。于是她说，好吧，你知道你确定吗？这算是你的时间。所以如果你能想到什么的话。
And I said, well, you know, I kind of do have these funny dreams sometimes. And she said, well, what do you dream about? And so I said, I always have these dreams, these horrific dreams where my dad's coming after me and sending bears after me, and we're just hollering at each other.
我说，嗯，你知道，我有时候确实会做这些奇怪的梦。她说，好吧，你梦见什么了？于是我说，我总是做这些梦，这些可怕的梦，我爸爸在追我，还派熊来追我，我们就只是在大声吼叫。
Beth explained that she and her father had a good relationship. Which is why these dreams always puzzled her. In her waking life, they rarely fought.
贝丝解释说，她和父亲关系很好。这就是为什么这些梦总是让她感到困惑。在现实生活中，他们很少争吵。
She then stopped me and she said to me, has anything ever happened to you? As a child? And she said by way of, like a sexual nature, where you were touched inappropriately or those kind of things. And I said, oh no. Absolutely not. And she said, well, usually people who have been abused by somebody-- these kind of dreams that you're having are indicative of having been abused. Of course, then that's when we hit our 15-minute time limit, or whatever we had left. And she says, well, I want you to go home and I want you to think. And see if you can remember anything.
然后她打断我说，她问我，以前发生过什么事吗？在你小时候？她说，那种方式，比如性方面的，你是否被不适当地触摸过，或者这类事情。我说，哦，没有。绝对没有。她说，好吧，通常那些被某人虐待过的人——你做的这些梦说明你被虐待过。当然，那时我们正好到了15分钟的时间限制，或者无论剩下什么时间。她说，好吧，我想要你回家，我想要你思考。看看能不能想起什么。
So I went home. And, again, I don't remember anything. I was 100% confident. I knew nothing had happened to me. And my concern was, I didn't want to leave any doubt in her mind-- because she knew my mom and dad-- wondering if they had done something to me.
于是我回家了。而且，再说一次，我不记得任何事。我100%确信。我知道什么都没发生在我身上。我担心的是，我不想在她心中留下任何怀疑——因为她认识我父母——怀疑他们是否对我做了什么。
So, anyway, we make the third appointment. And I go in. I said, I've thought about this stuff and I can't think of anything. And again, she started, well, are you sure? And then she explained to me that it is possible to have things happen to you and forget about them. And that you can have these horrific things done to you, and be a part of things and that you don't remember it. That's your body's way of coping.
所以，总之，我们定了第三次预约。我进去了。我说，我想过这些事，但我什么也想不起来。她再次开始说，你确定吗？然后她向我解释说，发生在你身上的事情是有可能被遗忘的。而且你可能会被这些可怕的事情对待，参与其中，但你不记得了。那是你身体的应对方式。
This therapist, Beth reasoned, was a professional. Someone with training. Perhaps she knew something about Beth that Beth did not know herself. Her therapist, by the way, declined to be interviewed for this story.
贝丝推断，这位治疗师是专业的。受过训练。也许她知道一些连贝丝自己都不知道的事。顺便说一句，她的治疗师拒绝接受本故事的采访。
But anyway, I should tell you that it took a long time-- 18 months-- for Beth to believe that she'd been sexually abused. This process began simply, with a detailed review of her childhood. And it was during these conversations that Beth's therapist would offer new interpretations of the ordinary facts of Beth's life. When Beth told her therapist, for example, that her parents had encouraged her to do well in school, her therapist suggested that perhaps this was done out of guilt.
但无论如何，我应该告诉你，花了很长时间——18个月——贝丝才相信自己曾受到性虐待。这个过程开始得很简单，是对她童年的详细回顾。正是在这些对话中，贝丝的治疗师会对贝丝生活中普通的事实提出新的解读。例如，当贝丝告诉治疗师父母鼓励她努力学习时，治疗师暗示这可能是出于内疚。
Was it possible they were trying to cover for some harm they'd done her? The therapist didn't know either, she was just asking. Beth, who was living at home to save money, began to avoid her family. She spent more time in her room.
是否有可能他们试图掩盖对她造成的伤害？治疗师也不知道，她只是在问。为了省钱住在家里的贝丝开始回避家人。她花更多时间待在房间里。
And then I was given books to read about stories of people that had been abused. And she'd actually pick out certain chapters for me to read. And it began obviously to preoccupy a lot of my time, thinking about this. Trying so hard to remember if something had happened. And I couldn't remember, and I'd try to think even more.
然后我得到了一些关于受虐待者故事的书来读。她甚至为我挑选了特定的章节来读。显然，这开始占据我大量的时间，思考这个问题。努力想要记起是否发生了什么。但我记不起来，我甚至尝试思考更多。
And anyway, reading this material, reading these books, I began to dream a lot. So part of our therapy sessions then would be, I would go in and tell her what I had dreamed. Well, then I was told, no Beth, those aren't dreams. They are flashbacks of what happened.
总之，读这些材料，读这些书，我开始经常做梦。所以我们的治疗环节有一部分变成了，我会进去告诉她我梦到了什么。好吧，然后我被告知，不贝丝，那些不是梦。它们是你所经历之事的闪回。
This idea, that dreams were not simply dreams, but could actually represent accurate memories, was an article of faith in repressed memory therapy. Now therapists are cautioned against it, but at the time it was one of a series of beliefs and techniques used to interpret and access buried trauma. A series of beliefs and techniques which hinged on a single psychiatric idea. Namely, that it was possible to experience profound trauma-- rape, sodomy, forced cannibalism-- and to erase all memory of those events from the conscious mind.
这种观点——梦不仅仅是梦，实际上可能代表准确的记忆——是压抑记忆疗法中的一条信条。现在治疗师们被警告要远离它，但在当时，它是用来解释和获取被掩埋创伤的一系列信念和技术之一。这一系列信念和技术围绕着一个精神病学思想。即，有可能经历深刻的创伤——强奸、鸡奸、强迫食人——并将所有这些事件的记忆从意识层面抹去。
When I called the American Psychological Association to ask for an expert who could explain how psychologists viewed the recovered memory movement today, I was referred to Michael Yapko, a practicing clinician who wrote a book about recovered memory therapy. He describes what went wrong this way.
当我打电话给美国心理学会寻找一位专家来解释心理学家今天如何看待恢复记忆运动时，我被转介给迈克尔·亚普科，一位写过关于恢复记忆疗法书籍的职业临床医生。他这样描述出了什么问题。
What this whole repressed memory controversy was fueled by were those clinicians who would have a client come to them in some form of distress. And it was the therapist who presupposed a history of abuse, and would literally say to the patient, I believe that you've been abused as a child and that's what explains your symptoms. Then the patient would say, well, that never happened to me. And then the therapist would nod his or her head and smile knowingly and say, well, you know, that's how repression works. You're obviously repressing those memories of abuse. We need to use these techniques, like guided imagery, hypnosis, whatever, to get at those memories and bring them forth. And that's the only way that you will recover.
这场关于压抑记忆的整个争议是由那些临床医生煽动的，他们会有带着某种痛苦的客户来找他们。是治疗师预设了虐待史，并会字面意义上对病人说，我相信你小时候被虐待过，这就是你症状的原因。然后病人会说，不，那从来没发生在我身上。然后治疗师会点头微笑，心知肚明地说，好吧，你知道，这就是压抑的作用。你显然压抑了那些被虐待的记忆。我们需要使用这些技术，比如引导意象、催眠、无论什么，来获取那些记忆并把它们带出来。这是你恢复的唯一途径。
The problem with these techniques, Yapko says, is that they didn't bring back accurate memories. Memory is vulnerable to suggestion. And not only could benign questions from a therapist contaminate the memories, the simple act of telling someone to try to remember could lead them to create details which simply weren't real.
亚普科说，这些技术的问题在于，它们带回的并不是准确的记忆。记忆容易受到暗示的影响。不仅治疗师的温和问题会污染记忆，简单地告诉某人尝试去回忆，就会导致他们创造出根本不真实的细节。
But these techniques were taught anyway in schools of psychiatry and psychology, in continuing education programs. There was massage to unleash body memories, hypnosis, and also guided imagery where patients like Beth were told to relax, to imagine themselves as a child.
但这些技术无论如何都在精神病学和心理学学校、继续教育项目中传授。有释放身体记忆的按摩、催眠，还有引导意象，像贝丝这样的患者被要求放松，想象自己小时候的样子。
I can remember, I'd kind of bend my head down a little bit. And I'm thinking and she'd talk to me. OK, now, think about where you were as a child. OK, think about sitting on your bed. So I'm thinking, thinking. OK, now what are you wearing? So I'm thinking, thinking. What's an outfit I can remember wearing as a child?
我记得，我会把头稍微低下来一点。我在思考，她跟我说话。好吧，现在，想想你小时候在哪里。好吧，想想坐在你的床上。所以我在想，在想。好吧，你穿的是什么？所以我我在想，在想。我能记得小时候穿的是什么衣服？
And then you just build on that, and build on it. And what did that feel like. You know, it's kind of like you have a little half teaspoon of memory, so to speak. That little half teaspoon turns into a whole three tiered cake.
然后你就在此基础上建立，不断建立。那感觉如何。你知道，这就好像你有一个小半茶匙的记忆，可以这么说。那一小半茶匙变成了整个三层蛋糕。
It was during these guided imagery sessions that Beth began to blank out. To lose conscious memory of portions of her therapy sessions. Concentrating so hard on the images she was conjuring that she worked herself into a kind of hypnotic state.
正是在这些引导意象的环节中，贝丝开始大脑空白。失去对部分治疗过程的清醒记忆。如此专注地关注她所唤起的意象，以至于她把自己带入了一种催眠状态。
I remember the first time it happened, it scared me to death, because I kind of looked up to her. And she said to me, do you know what just happened? I said, no, what? And she said, you just recounted for me a story of what had happened to. What your dad had done. And she has a piece of paper. And she's told me she wrote down everything I said. And then she started, and she began to read back to me.
我记得第一次发生这种情况时，我被吓坏了，因为我有点崇拜她。她说，你知道刚刚发生了什么吗？我说，不，发生了什么？她说，你刚刚向我重述了一个故事，关于你所经历的事。关于你爸爸对你做过的事。她有一张纸。她告诉我她写下了我说的所有话。然后她开始，她开始向我读回我所说的话。
I can hardly describe the horror, to sit there and listen to that.
我几乎无法描述那种恐惧，坐在那儿听着那些话。
She's saying I said it. She's reading it to me, as I described an event where my dad had brought me to my mom and his bedroom and laid down next to me. She's describing, and it was so horrifying. I can't hardly describe for somebody what it's like to believe that you have been loved as a child, and you grew up in a wonderful home. And to sit there and listen.
她说是我说的。她读给我听，我描述了一个事件，我爸爸把我带到他和妈妈的卧室，躺在我身边。她描述着，那太可怕了。我几乎无法向别人描述这种感觉是什么，相信你小时候被爱着，在美满的家庭中长大。然后坐在那儿听。
And it's literally like the foundation of your life is coming apart.
这真的就像你生活的地基正在解体。
I became a therapist because I wanted to help people.
我成为治疗师是因为我想帮助别人。
Linda Ross graduated with a master's in counseling in 1986, but most of her training in recovered memory therapy took place after that, in the continuing education seminars she took to keep current. These classes provided long list of possible symptoms. Gave tutorials in guided imagery, in dreams, body memories. All the modern thinking. Because Linda felt she was in a field of study that was scientifically based, she assumed these ideas had been properly researched and tested. That her responsibility was simply to follow them faithfully, which Linda did.
琳达·罗斯在1986年获得了心理咨询硕士学位，但她大部分关于恢复记忆疗法的训练是在那之后发生的，在为了保持知识更新而参加的继续教育研讨会上。这些课程提供了可能症状的长清单。教授了引导意象、梦境、身体记忆的教程。所有现代思维。因为琳达觉得她处于一个科学基础的领域，她假设这些想法已经经过适当的研究和测试。她的责任只是忠实地遵循它们，琳达确实做到了。
After graduation, she began working for an agency near her home. She dealt with a variety of issues, but developed a sub-specialty in sexual abuse. And soon she was fielding referrals from half a dozen churches and social service centers in her area.
毕业后，她开始在离家不远的一家机构工作。她处理各种各样的问题，但发展出了性虐待方面的专业特长。很快她就开始处理来自当地半打教会和社会服务中心的转介病人。
The vast majority of these patients were women who remembered their abuse. But in the early 90s, Linda had a series of clients who uncovered repressed memories. Some of these memories were deeply troubling. There were stories of child pornography rings and satanic rituals. And then there was a woman whose guided imagery session revealed that she had witnessed a murder.
绝大多数这些病人是记得自己被虐待经历的女性。但在90年代初，琳达遇到了一系列揭开压抑记忆的客户。其中一些记忆极其令人不安。有关于儿童色情团伙和撒旦仪式的故事。还有一个女人，她的引导意象环节揭示了她目睹了一场谋杀。
Her father had taken his preteen daughter to the woods, where he slaughtered a man and his son in cold blood while his daughter looked on.
她的父亲带着她十几岁的女儿去了树林，在那里冷血地屠杀了一名男子和他的儿子，而他的女儿就在旁边看着。
As she was taking you through this scene, what were you thinking?
当她带你经历这个场景时，你在想什么？
I was thinking how horrible. What an awful thing for a little girl to have to go through. You know, I had no doubt in my mind that this had happened.
我在想多么可怕。多么糟糕的事情，一个小女孩不得不经历。你知道，我心里毫无疑问这是发生过的。
Partially, Linda believed because she's been trained to believe. Had been told that in these delicate matters, the therapist was not supposed to question. This above all was an unbreachable rule.
琳达部分认为是因为她受到的教育让她相信。在这些敏感问题上，治疗师不应该质疑。这最重要的是一条不可逾越的规则。
And of course it's completely reinforced by the depth of her pain. It's completely reinforced by the sharpness and acuity of her memory. Even if I had a doubt, I wasn't going to doubt, because her memory was so sharp, her emotions were so genuine. And so, she reinforced my idea in the belief of it. And then, of course, I responded by being horrified and comforting. Which reinforced her idea that I believed it. And so I didn't see how we were a feedback loop. I didn't get that.
当然，这完全被她痛苦的深度所强化。它完全被她记忆的清晰度和敏锐度所强化。即使我有疑问，我也不会怀疑，因为她的记忆太清晰了，她的情绪太真实了。所以，她强化了我相信这一点的想法。当然，我的反应是感到惊恐并予以安慰。这强化了她认为我相信这一点的想法。所以我没看到我们是如何形成反馈循环的。我没意识到。
But it was more than that. Linda believed not only because she'd been trained to believe, but because on some deep level it appealed to a romantic ideal. This notion she had, that she was a healer.
但不仅仅是这样。琳达相信不仅是因为她受过训练去相信，还因为在某种深层层面上，它迎合了一个浪漫的理想。她拥有的这个观念，即她是一位疗愈者。
This part of me that wants to be the hero, felt like, I'm going to believe you, and I'm going to be here for you, and I'm going to be on your side, and I'm going to help you heal. It really was appealing to sort of the best in me.
我想成为英雄的那部分感觉，我想，我会相信你，我会支持你，我会站在你这边，我会帮你疗愈。它真的触动了某种我心中最好的一面。
As time went on, Beth Rutherford's memories got more and more bizarre. She remembered curling irons and steak forks. And a pregnancy which her father tried to abort with a coat hanger. Years later, she went to a doctor who confirmed, after a 15-minute examination, that Beth was actually a virgin. That none of this could be true. But at the time these memories were so vivid that Beth could recall the most intimate details. The feel of the curling iron. The rope around her ankles.
随着时间推移，贝丝·卢瑟福的记忆变得越来越离奇。她记得卷发棒和牛排叉。还有一个父亲试图用挂衣钩堕胎的怀孕经历。多年后，她去看了一位医生，经过15分钟的检查，证实贝丝实际上是一位处女。这些都不可能是真的。但在当时，这些记忆是如此生动，以至于贝丝能回忆起最隐秘的细节。卷发棒的感觉。脚踝上的绳子。
And like many patients who faced memories of this kind, Beth began to deteriorate. The psychological strain taking a physical toll. She stopped eating and dropped to 80 pounds. And had trouble sleeping through the night. She began to take  pills. Rather than interpret Beth's sickness as a sign that the therapy wasn't working, her therapist saw the deterioration as evidence that they simply needed to work harder.
而且像许多面对这类记忆的患者一样，贝丝开始恶化。心理压力造成了身体上的损害。她停止进食，体重降到了80磅。而且很难整夜睡觉。她开始服用药片。治疗师并没有把贝丝的生病解读为治疗无效的迹象，而是将这种恶化视为他们仅仅需要更努力工作的证据。
In other words, the failure of recovered memory therapy to restore Beth's mental health led her therapist to pressure Beth for more memories, which undermined Beth's health further, and led to the creation of even more.
换句话说，恢复记忆疗法在恢复贝丝心理健康方面的失败，导致治疗师向贝丝施压要求更多记忆，这进一步损害了贝丝的健康，并导致创造了更多（虚假记忆）。
It basically became this thing that, well, you're deteriorating because you haven't been bringing up any more memories. Because there's still something there and it's bothering you. And until you get it all out, and we get to the bottom of this, you're never going to get better. You are always going to be like this until you get to the bottom.
这基本上变成了一种情况，好吧，你正在恶化，因为你没有带出更多记忆。因为还有什么东西在那里，它在困扰你。在你把它全部拿出来，在我们搞清楚之前，你永远不会变好。直到你搞清楚为止，你永远会是这样。
Like most therapists trained in recovered memory, Linda Ross had been taught to expect deterioration. But then several of Linda's patients seemed to go into free fall. It was around this time that Linda first heard of the False Memory Syndrome Foundation, an organization founded in 1992, which had become a resource for accused parents who thought that their children had been led into false beliefs through therapy.
像大多数受过恢复记忆训练的治疗师一样，琳达·罗斯被教导要预见到恶化。但随后琳达的几位病人似乎进入了自由落体状态。正是在这段时间里，琳达第一次听说了“虚假记忆综合征基金会”，这是一个成立于1992年的组织，它成为了那些认为自己的孩子通过治疗被引导进入虚假信念的被告父母的资源。
The parents of one of Linda's patients had come across the organization after their daughter's memories led to a police investigation. And they sent Linda some brochures.
琳达的一位病人的父母在女儿的记忆导致警方调查后发现了这个组织。他们给琳达寄了一些小册子。
I said thank you very much. I took the information. And I said, you know, this is a place for people who have perpetrated these horrible crimes to just now hideout and pretend like these things didn't really happen. And when I when I look at my culpability in all of this, I really count that as the place where-- you know, prior to that I had really been acting on good faith out of ignorance. But really based on what I thought was sound counseling from the people that had trained me. But I had a moment there to begin to just say, well, let me look at it from another angle. And I very willfully chose not to.
我说非常感谢。我拿了信息。我说，你知道，这是一个让那些实施这些可怕罪行的人现在隐藏起来，假装这些事情并没有真正发生的地方。当我审视自己在这一切中的罪责时，我真的认为那是——你知道，在此之前，我真的出于无知在善意行事。但确实是基于我认为从训练我的人那里学到的健全咨询经验。但我当时有一个时刻，本可以开始说，好吧，让我从另一个角度看看。但我非常任性地选择了不看。
Why do you think you chose not to?
你为什么觉得你选择了不看？
Because if I chose to believe something different then it was going to mean that I had been doing something very wrong to a number of families, and I was going to have to face myself.
因为如果我选择相信不同的东西，那就意味着我一直在对许多家庭做非常错误的事情，我将不得不面对我自己。
In fact, during the early 90s, therapists found themselves believing all kinds of stories. Stories which, on their face, now seem outrageous. Well-appointed, middle-class women would walk into suburban offices, close their eyes for guided imagery, and talk about being forced to watch dozens of people sacrificed in satanic rituals. Or being sodomized by whole police departments. And the therapists, trained clinicians, would nod their heads in sympathy and horror.
事实上，在90年代初，治疗师发现自己相信各种各样的故事。这些故事表面上看起来现在显得非常离谱。衣着整齐的中产阶级女性会走进郊区的办公室，闭上眼睛进行引导意象，谈论被迫观看数十人在撒旦仪式中被祭祀。或者被整个警察部门鸡奸。而那些治疗师，受过训练的临床医生，会带着同情和惊恐点头。
As Michael Yapko points out, therapists were laboring under the assumption that if something truly horrible had happened, it would be repressed. And so their acceptance of these stories makes a certain sense.
正如迈克尔·亚普科指出的那样，治疗师在这样的假设下工作：如果真正可怕的事情发生了，它就会被压抑。所以他们接受这些故事在某种程度上是合理的。
And here's where a little bit of history helps. Literally up until the late 1970s, the viewpoint that predominated the field was that when somebody came in and reported a history of sexual abuse as a child, that this was dismissed as a psychological fantasy. And that started with Freud and it continued all the way, literally, up until the 1970s. And then finally, in the 1970s, riding the wave of feminism, researchers came in and said, you know, all these women say that they were abused as children, and everybody's discounting it. Before we discount it, how about if we find out whether it's really true or not.
这里有一点历史知识很有帮助。字面上直到70年代末，该领域占主导地位的观点是，当有人进来报告童年性虐待史时，这被视为一种心理幻想。这从弗洛伊德开始，一直持续到70年代。然后最终，在70年代，乘着女权主义的浪潮，研究人员进来说，你知道，所有这些女性都说她们小时候被虐待过，大家都在怀疑。在我们怀疑之前，如果我们调查一下这是否属实怎么样。
And then they started doing research on the prevalence of child abuse, and guess what they discovered? That females were being abused and in very large numbers.
然后他们开始做关于虐待儿童普遍性的研究，猜猜他们发现了什么？女性正在被虐待，而且数量非常巨大。
And so, with the best of intentions, the experts came to see abuse everywhere. Even in people who hadn't been abused. And their conviction, their sense of righteousness, helped convince patients like Beth Rutherford. And this is one of the most disturbing aspects of these cases. That in the hands of even the most mild-mannered experts, people like Beth, normal people with normal relationships with their parents, could come to believe horrible things about the people they loved most.
于是，出于最好的意愿，专家们开始到处看到虐待。即使在那些没被虐待过的人身上。他们的坚定，他们的正义感，帮助说服了像贝丝·卢瑟福这样的病人。这是这些案例中最令人不安的方面之一。即使在最温文尔雅的专家手中，像贝丝这样的人，与父母关系正常的普通人，也会开始相信关于他们最爱的人的可怕事情。
I didn't want to believe that that had happened to me. It's something that came from the therapy and it was-- and I was told I had to do this or I was never going to get better. If I didn't do this, I was going to do it to my own children. And I remember her, so to speak, complimenting me and congratulating me on being the person that's breaking this cycle in my family.
我不想相信那发生在我身上。这是来自治疗的东西，它是——而且我被告知我必须这样做，否则我就永远不会变好。如果我不这样做，我就会对我自己的孩子做同样的事。我记得她，可以这么说，称赞并祝贺我是那个在我家庭中打破这种循环的人。
After two and a half years of breaking the cycle, Beth's therapist began to pressure Beth to go public. To formally accuse her father, who was then working as an administrator at the Assembly of God headquarters, the same church where Beth's therapist worked as a counselor.
在打破这种循环两年半之后，贝丝的治疗师开始向贝丝施压，要求她公开。去正式控告她的父亲，他当时在神召会总部担任行政主管，也就是贝丝的治疗师作为咨询师工作的同一个教会。
For weeks, Beth resisted. She'd never confronted her parents, had simply emotionally withdrawn from the family. But Beth's therapist wouldn't give up. And so one Wednesday in October, three years after her therapy began, Beth arrived at her session and was presented with a document and a choice. She could either sign a formal accusation of her father, which would be submitted to the denominational authority, or all the files in Beth's case would be given to the local district attorney, a man who would prosecute her father to the full extent of the law.
几周来，贝丝一直在反抗。她从未质问过她的父母，只是在情感上疏远了家庭。但贝丝的治疗师不会放弃。所以十月的一个周三，在治疗开始三年后，贝丝来到她的会谈中，被出示了一份文件和一个选择。她要么签署一份正式的父亲控告书，提交给教派权威，要么她案例中的所有档案都会交给当地地区检察官，那个会全力起诉她父亲的人。
Given these options, Beth signed the paper. And several weeks later, her dad lost his job, and was ordered to appear at a church hearing.
考虑到这些选项，贝丝签署了文件。几周后，她爸爸丢了工作，并被命令出席教会听证会。
And we sit down. And they greet us. We greet them. And probably three minutes passed, and he is reading a statement to me.
我们坐下来。他们迎接我们。我们迎接他们。大概过了三分钟，他在读一份给我的声明。
This is Tom Rutherford, Beth's father.
这是汤姆·卢瑟福，贝丝的父亲。
"Tom, it has been brought to our attention"-- I have a copy of it-- "that one of your daughters is alleging that she has been sexually molested as a child growing up in your home."
“汤姆，我们注意到”——我有一份复印件——“你的一位女儿指控她在你家中长大时受到了性猥亵。”
There's actually a long and sad story to tell about these proceedings and the meetings which followed. It's a story of public humiliation and pain, the kind of narrative most likely familiar to anyone who's followed the coverage of false memory incidents over the last 10 years. In this case, Tom and his wife Joyce were subjected to a series of hearings. Hearings which tried to determine whether or not they were pedophiles.
关于这些程序和随后的会议，其实有一个漫长而悲伤的故事。这是一个关于公开羞辱和痛苦的故事，这种叙事方式对于过去10年关注“虚假记忆”事件报道的任何人来说可能都很熟悉。在这个案例中，汤姆和他的妻子乔伊斯遭受了一系列听证会。这些听证会试图确定他们是否是恋童癖。
They didn't know who believe. So they asked Joyce and I to submit ourselves to going to a professional clinic, of their choosing, to be psychologically and emotionally and all evaluated to see if we could be child molesters.
他们不知道该相信谁。所以他们要求乔伊斯和我去一家他们选择的专业诊所，进行心理和情感等多方面的评估，看我们是否可能是虐待儿童的人。
And asking me to go to be psychologically evaluated would be no different to me than asking me to go to the hospital to have a hysterectomy. That is as much sense as that meant to me. By the end, this thing had gone public. It went public in this community, it went public everywhere. We even went to the mall, and there were good friends that would see us coming and they would raise their hands up, and just shake their head and turn and go the other way.
要求我去进行心理评估，对我来说和要求我去医院做子宫切除术没什么区别。这对我的意义就是这样。到最后，这件事公开了。它在这个社区公开了，它到处都公开了。我们甚至去购物中心，有很好的朋友看到我们走过来，他们会举起手，摇摇头，转过身向另一个方向走去。
After the story went public, Tom couldn't find work. He was turned away by over 100 potential employers. He and Joyce were forbidden to contact Beth, who had moved to Oklahoma City, and were cautioned not to contact their other daughters as well. Tom had lost his family, his position, his name. Quite understandably, he struggled with thoughts of suicide, an act he believed was a sin.
故事公开后，汤姆找不到工作。他被100多位潜在雇主拒绝。他和乔伊斯被禁止联系贝丝，贝丝已经搬到了俄克拉荷马城，并被告知也不要联系她们的其他女儿。汤姆失去了他的家庭、职位、名誉。可以理解，他挣扎着想到自杀，一个他认为是罪的行为。
There were times when my head hit the pillow at night-- I pleaded that God would be more merciful to me if he would just allow me not to awaken in the morning. And there were times when I would be home, and I'm unemployed, and I'd turn on music. And I played music-- tapes and records and things-- and I played it so loud so I couldn't hear myself think. Just to save my sanity. And try to make it another 24 hours.
有几次当我的头晚上碰到枕头时——我祈求上帝如果能让我早上不再醒来，他会对我更仁慈。有时我在家，我失业了，我打开音乐。我播放音乐——磁带、唱片之类的——我把它开得很大声，这样我就听不到自己的思考。只是为了保住我的理智。并试图再撑过24小时。
Again, Linda Ross, the therapist in Arizona.
再次是琳达·罗斯，亚利桑那州的治疗师。
So finally this client comes to me and she tells me that she has a memory of a woman in the neighborhood had miscarried, and her mother had been there helping this neighbor. And her mother took the fetus, brought it home, heated up some oil, boiled the fetus in oil and made her eat the arm of the fried baby. And it was at that point that I said, you know what? I don't think this happened. I don't believe that.
所以最后这个客户来找我，她告诉我她有一个记忆，邻居里的一位女性流产了，她的母亲一直在那里帮助这位邻居。她的母亲拿走了胎儿，带回家，加热了一些油，把胎儿煮在油里，并让她吃了那炸婴儿的手臂。就在那一刻，我说，你知道吗？我不觉得这发生过。我不相信那个。
I was in a panic. Because the thing that I had been trained-- you do not disbelieve your clients. If you do, you're Satan. And I didn't believe her.
我陷入了恐慌。因为我受到的训练——你绝对不要不相信你的客户。如果你这样做，你就是撒旦。而我不相信她。
After several sleepless nights, Linda decided to confront her patient directly.
经过几个不眠之夜，琳达决定直接与她的病人对质。
That was one of the hardest, scariest moments in my life. And at that point it wasn't like I've had this moment of clarity. You know, I need to tell you and I-- you have to understand, I had never heard that there was any possibility that repressed memories could be false. I'd never heard that thought. I had no context other than my own self which said, I don't believe this. So I felt like a failure. I felt like I was failing this client. I was failing myself. But I could not overcome my own doubt. And so I, you know, I just told her, I have a hard time believing this particular memory. And you have a right to be in therapy with someone who's going to believe you.
那是我一生中最艰难、最可怕的时刻之一。在那一点上，不像我有了顿悟。你知道，我需要告诉你，而且我——你必须明白，我从来没听说过压抑的记忆可能是虚假的这种可能性。我从没想过这个想法。除了我自己的内心告诉我“我不相信这件事”之外，我没有任何背景。所以我感到自己是一个失败者。我觉得我在辜负这个客户。我在辜负我自己。但我无法克服我自己的怀疑。所以，你知道，我只是告诉她，我很难相信这个特定的记忆。而你有权和一位会相信你的人一起接受治疗。
And to my discredit, I sent her on to someone who was a specialist in working with satanic ritual abuse and multiple personalities. And then she got much worse.
由于我的失职，我把她转给了另一位专门从事撒旦仪式虐待和多重人格治疗的专家。然后她的情况变得更糟了。
Beth Rutherford was living in Oklahoma City with her sister, Lynette, who dropped out of college after her father's disgrace. It was a terrible time. They're completely alone, they had no jobs, no acquaintances, and very little money. Beth spent nights on the bathroom floor crying. But then Beth stopped talking to her therapist. And, miraculously, she began to feel better. She got a job, put on weight. Things seemed to be returning to normal.
贝丝·卢瑟福和她的姐妹琳内特住在俄克拉荷马城，琳内特在父亲蒙羞后退了学。那是一段可怕的时光。她们完全孤独，没有工作，没有熟人，钱也很少。贝丝在浴室地板上哭着度过夜晚。但后来贝丝停止了和她的治疗师交谈。奇迹般地，她开始感觉好起来。她找到了一份工作，体重增加了。事情似乎正在恢复正常。
And then came the bombing at the Federal Building, and the tearful message on the answering machine from Beth's mother, who called, despite warnings from the church authorities that she and her husband could be prosecuted for harassment, simply to say that she loved Beth, she missed Beth, and she wanted to know if Beth was OK. This call was followed by another, and then another. Beth says it wasn't a certain moment, it was a series of moments. A collection of calls and gentle suggestions from her sisters, from family members, which finally produced the meetings.
然后联邦大楼发生了爆炸案，贝丝的母亲在电话留言机上留下了饱含泪水的消息，尽管教会当局警告她和丈夫可能会因骚扰被起诉，她还是打电话来，只是为了说她爱贝丝，她想念贝丝，她想知道贝丝是否还好。这个电话之后又是另一个，然后又是一个。贝丝说这不是特定的时刻，是一系列时刻。一系列来自她的姐妹、家人的电话和温柔建议，最终促成了会面。
First with her mother, a shopping trip at a local mall. And then later, her father, whom she saw for the first time in the kitchen of her aunt's house in Tulsa. At that point she still believed and had only reluctantly agreed to stand in the same room as her father at all. And so this meeting took her by surprise.
首先是她的母亲，在当地购物中心的一次购物之行。后来是她的父亲，她在塔尔萨她姑姑家厨房里第一次见到他。那时她仍然相信（那些记忆），并且只是勉强同意和父亲站在同一个房间里。所以这次会面让她感到意外。
I come down the stairs and I come into the kitchen, and I am scared to death.
我走下楼梯来到厨房，我被吓坏了。
In walks Beth to go over to get a cup of coffee.
贝丝走过来想倒杯咖啡。
And out of the corner of my eye, I see my dad walking across the kitchen. I thought, he's coming over here to hit me.
在我眼角的余光里，我看到我爸爸走过厨房。我想，他过来是要打我。
And here she was, and I didn't know what to say, what I should do, what would be proper? How do you break the ice? All I knew was to go over there.
她就在那儿，我不知道该说什么，我该做什么，什么才是合适的？你怎么打破僵局？我只知道要走过去。
And I see him walk across the kitchen, and he comes over and he stands right next to me and he just started crying.
我看到他走过厨房，他走过来，站在我旁边，他开始哭。
And I didn't know what to say. And she starts to cry. And I said, if it's all right with you, can I say your name? She kind of nodded her head. And I said, Beth. I love you, Beth.
我不知道该说什么。她开始哭。我说，如果你不介意的话，我可以叫你的名字吗？她点了点头。我说，贝丝。我爱你，贝丝。
I remember thinking, in my mind, as I'm driving, this does not line up. That man that was just in the kitchen does not match who I have in my head of who he is.
我记得在开车时，心里想，这不对劲。那个刚才在厨房里的男人和我脑海中关于他是谁的形象不匹配。
As for Linda Ross, the breaking point came shortly after a confrontation with a client. Came in the form of a letter, sent by one of her old patients, a woman who'd come to believe that the memory she'd recovered in therapy with Linda had been false. This letter included an invitation. The woman wanted Linda to attend an event sponsored by the False Memory Syndrome Foundation. A meeting for parents who had felt they'd been falsely accused.
至于琳达·罗斯，崩溃点发生在她与一位客户对质后不久。以一封信的形式到来，是由她的一位老病人寄来的，一个女人开始相信她在琳达治疗中恢复的记忆是虚假的。这封信包括了一份邀请。那个女人希望琳达参加由“虚假记忆综合征基金会”赞助的一个活动。一个为那些觉得被虚假指控的父母准备的会议。
So I walk into this room with all these parents. Now, you know, I had been dealing with the daughters of-- not these particular folks-- but these folks, so to speak. And I really hadn't seen this from what this is like on their side. You know, what this looks like. And I walk in, and here are these sad, depressed, anxious parents who have been accused of horrible things. Horrible. Just so ridiculous.
所以我走进这个房间，里面全是这些父母。现在，你知道，我一直在处理这些女儿们——不是这些特定的人——而是这些人，可以这么说。我真的没从她们的角度看过这是什么样。你知道，这看起来像什么。我走进去，这里全是那些悲伤、抑郁、焦虑的父母，他们被指控了可怕的事情。可怕。简直荒谬。
And when you have it isolated, you have one little client sitting in front of you and they're making this accusation, it feels like, OK, well this is possible. This could happen. But then when you multiply it with the hundreds and thousands and thousands of people in therapy, and the number of people who have been murdered, and the number of people who've been sacrificed, and the number of people who've eaten the pizza boy, and the number of people who have been locked in basements. You know, you just begin to realize the magnitude of what I had been a little tiny microcosm.
当你孤立地看这件事时，你面前坐着一个小客户，她们做出这个指控，感觉就像，好吧，这可能是真的。这可能发生。但当你把它乘以接受治疗的成百上千上万的人，被谋杀的人数，被献祭的人数，吃掉披萨外送员的人数，被锁在地下室的人数。你知道，你只是开始意识到我的规模，我曾经是一个多么微小的缩影。
Shortly after this, the former patient invited Linda to yet another meeting. This one with the patient's parents, a sweet suburban couple who had had their home dismantled by a crew of local police officers, eager to uncover evidence of the dead bodies their daughter had remembered through therapy.
此后不久，这位前病人邀请琳达参加了又一次会议。这次是和病人的父母，一对甜蜜的郊区夫妇，他们的家被一群当地警察拆毁了，他们急于找出她女儿通过治疗恢复的尸体证据。
So we're all sitting together in this room, and she's beginning to tell them about how she came to believe this and all of this. And here I am, you know, I've played a part in this. So I had a chance to tell them the part that I played. And to tell them that I completely understood that they would find it difficult, for the rest of their lives, to be able to find a place to forgive me. But that I was certainly aware that I was in need of their forgiveness.
所以我们坐在一起，她开始告诉他们她是如何相信这一切的。我在这里，你知道，我在其中扮演了一个角色。所以我有一个机会告诉他们我扮演的角色。告诉他们我完全理解他们会觉得很难，在他们的余生中，能够找到宽恕我的地方。但我确实意识到我需要他们的宽恕。
And do you know what they did?
你知道他们做了什么吗？
What did they do?
他们做了什么？
They forgave me.
他们宽恕了我。
And it's because of them, I told them at that point that if I could ever speak up and talk about this issue in a way that would prevent other families from going through this, that I would. And I'm talking to you because of that promise that I made to them.
正因为他们，我在那一刻告诉他们，如果我能以一种方式公开谈论这个问题，防止其他家庭经历这些，我会的。我之所以和你谈话就是因为我给他们的那个承诺。
It was after this meeting that Linda decided to contact the rest of her patients. She wanted to apologize, and also to explain. To meet face-to-face and tell them the memories they'd recovered together might not be real. It was a painful process. A few of her patients had had explosive confrontations with their parents, and flat out rejected the idea that their members could be false. Some were angry, others simply devastated.
正是这次会议之后，琳达决定联系她其他的病人。她想道歉，也想解释。面对面交流，告诉她们她们一起恢复的记忆可能不是真实的。这是一个痛苦的过程。她有几个病人与父母发生了爆发性的对质，并完全拒绝了她们的成员（记忆）可能是虚假的想法。有些人很生气，另一些人只是感到崩溃。
The Sunday after Beth Rutherford met her father, she went to see the pastor of her church. She told this man what she'd been going through, and asked if she could spend some time alone in the chapel. She said she needed to think. Her pastor agreed. And after the evening service, cleared everyone out, locking the doors of the chapel from the outside. Beth stayed alone in the building for hours.
贝丝·卢瑟福见到父亲后的那个周日，她去见了自己的牧师。她告诉这个人她所经历的一切，并问她是否可以在礼拜堂单独待一会儿。她说她需要思考。她的牧师同意了。在晚祷后，清理了所有人，从外面锁上了礼拜堂的门。贝丝独自在建筑里待了几个小时。
And it's like things came into my thinking and I'm thinking, you know, I didn't have any of this before I went into therapy. I didn't have any of these memories, nothing was there. I believed I had a wonderful childhood. And by the time I left that night-- and I can't really explain, because it wasn't a certain minute, but it was like a process in those couple hours. By the time I left, I'd come to the point that I believed, OK, I don't think any of this happened to me.
事情进入了我的思考，我在想，你知道，在去治疗之前我没有这些东西。我没有任何这些记忆，什么都没有。我相信我有一个美好的童年。到那天晚上我离开的时候——我真的无法解释，因为那不是特定的分钟，但在那几个小时里是一个过程。当我离开时，我已经达到了我相信的地步，好吧，我不认为这一切发生在我身上。
Today, the consensus among mainstream psychiatrists and psychologists is that it is possible to experience great trauma and repress to it so deeply that you can't remember it. But that this kind of massive repression is rare. It's also generally agreed that therapists can inadvertently lead patients to create false memories with techniques like hypnosis and guided meditation. They need to be very cautious.
今天，主流精神病学家和心理学家的共识是，经历巨大的创伤并深深压抑它是可能的，以至于你无法记起。但这类的巨大压抑是罕见的。大家也普遍认为，治疗师可能会无意中引导患者通过催眠和引导冥想等技术创造虚假记忆。他们需要非常谨慎。
Of course, there are still therapists who use these techniques improperly. And there's no real way to police them. One psychologist in Philadelphia was sued by dozens of patients who came to remember satanic abuse under her care, but continues to practice today. She lost her psychology license. She calls herself a psychotherapist, which in many states is entirely legal.
当然，仍然有治疗师不当地使用这些技术。而且没有真正的方法来监管他们。费城的一位心理学家被数十名病人在她的照料下回忆起撒旦虐待而起诉，但今天仍在执业。她失去了心理学执照。她称自己为心理治疗师，在许多州这是完全合法的。
I went to college in the early 90s, at the height of the recovered memory movement. And, like most people my age, I can name, off the top of my head, three or four people who recovered memories. Who came to believe that they'd been horribly violated by those closest to them. Unlike Beth Rutherford, none of the people I know broke off contact with their families. There were no public hearings, no newspaper articles, no million dollar settlements. Their parents didn't write anguished letters to the False Memory Foundation. Nothing so spectacular.
我在90年代初上大学，正值恢复记忆运动的鼎盛时期。像我这个年龄的大多数人一样，我可以随口说出三四个人恢复了记忆。她们开始相信自己受到了最亲近的人的严重侵害。与贝丝·卢瑟福不同，我认识的人都没有断绝与家人的联系。没有公开听证会，没有报纸文章，没有数百万美元的赔偿。她们的父母没有写给虚假记忆基金会痛苦的信。没有什么那么壮观。
Instead, quietly, painfully, this idea that they were victims was simply integrated into their notion of themselves, and then they moved on, and carried this idea, real or false, with them.
相反，悄悄地、痛苦地，她们是受害者的想法只是被整合进她们对自己的看法中，然后她们继续前进，带着这个想法，无论真假，与她们同行。
According to a recent study, a survey of over 1,000 families whose children recovered memories during the early 90s, almost 50% of the men and women who recovered memories during that time have returned to their families, after a long period of estrangement, and are now attempting some kind of reconciliation. Many continue to believe that they were victimized by their families, and only a small portion, 10% or 12% have retracted and now believe that their memories were false.
根据最近的一项研究，对1000多个孩子在90年代初恢复记忆的家庭进行的调查，在那个时期恢复记忆的人中，有近50%的人在经历了一段漫长的疏远后回到了家人身边，现在正在尝试某种和解。许多人继续认为自己受到了家人的伤害，只有一小部分，10%或12%的人收回了说法，现在认为她们的记忆是虚假的。
On the other hand, there are almost no people like Linda Ross, practicing therapists, who have come forward to talk publicly about their experience. To admit culpability or try to figure out how this happened. The experts for once are strangely quiet.
另一方面，几乎没有像琳达·罗斯这样执业的治疗师站出来公开谈论她们的经历。承认罪责或试图搞清这是怎么发生的。专家们这次异常安静。
Alix Spiegel, in New York.
艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔，在纽约。
Coming up, it's one thing to do a little improv in front of your acting class. It's another to do it in front of Marlon Brando. The scariest acting class in the world, in a minute, from Public Radio International and Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，在表演课前做一点即兴表演是一回事。在马龙·白兰度面前做是另一回事。世界上最可怕的表演课，稍后回来，来自国际公共广播电台和芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续。
It's This America Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose some theme. Bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Ask an expert." Stories about experts giving terrible, terrible advice. We've arrived at act two of our show. Act two, "Not Stella Adler, just still Stellllaaah."
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题。为您带来各种不同种类的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目，“问问专家”。关于专家给出糟糕、糟糕建议的故事。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“不是斯特拉·阿德勒，只是斯——特——拉”。
I don't know if it's true that those who can't do teach-- you know that saying. I want to know more about those who can do. Can they teach? Recently, one of the greatest actors of the last century, somebody who is reclusive, and who doesn't usually speak about his own work in public, decided to make a set of instructional videos about acting. The actor is Marlon Brando. His instructional videos are called Lying for a Living. They aren't on the market just yet. Jod Kaftan visited Brando's compound in Beverly Hills while they were being put together.
我不知道“那些不会做的人教书”这句谚语是否属实。我想了解更多关于那些会做的人。他们能教吗？最近，上个世纪最伟大的演员之一，一个隐居、平时不在公开场合谈论自己工作的家伙，决定制作一套关于表演的教学视频。这位演员就是马龙·白兰度。他的教学视频名为《以谎言为生》。它们还没上市。乔德·卡夫坦在这些视频制作期间访问了白兰度在比佛利山庄的宅邸。
The scariest thing about Marlon Brando is his phone. I ask if I can call New York from his office. But I'm warned by his staff that someone may listen in. I'm foolishly curious and call anyway. Indeed, in the middle of my conversation, I faintly detect a third party's breathing, and a receiver fumbling in someone's hands. I say, hello? More breathing. I hear what sounds like the crunch of a potato chip. I end the call and hang up.
马龙·白兰度最可怕的是他的电话。我问是否可以从他的办公室打给纽约。但我被他的员工警告说可能有人在监听。我愚蠢地好奇，还是打了。确实，在谈话中间，我隐约察觉到第三方的呼吸声，还有某人手中摆弄接收器的声音。我说，你好？更多的呼吸声。我听到像是嚼薯片的声音。我结束通话挂断了。
The office at Brando's estate is shrouded in a bamboo thicket off the driveway. Any minute he could beep on the phone, to indicate that he'd like to walk over and see the first footage from his new project on acting called Lying for a Living. The staff seems anxious. Someone is feverishly collecting empty soda cans. Another usually chatty staffer is suddenly mute and typing dutifully.
白兰度庄园的办公室隐藏在车道旁的竹丛中。随时他都可能在电话上发出哔哔声，表示他想走过来看看他的新表演项目《以谎言为生》的第一部分录像。员工们似乎很焦虑。有人正在狂热地收集空汽水罐。另一个平时健谈的员工突然沉默了，勤奋地打着字。
Immediately I scan the office for strange cuckoo clocks, or oil paintings with roving eyes. Beep. Everyone stops and looks at the phone.
我立刻扫描办公室寻找奇怪的布谷鸟钟或眼球转动的油画。哔。每个人都停下来看着电话。
There's a mumble. A raspy, congested voice says, "Coming down." I'm sitting on the couch with my legs crossed, fighting the urge to look over my shoulder. I know I shouldn't since he once told me that he hates being stared at, especially by men.
传来一阵嘟囔。一个沙哑、鼻音很重的声音说，“下去。”我双腿交叉坐在沙发上，强忍着回头看的冲动。我知道我不应该这样做，因为他曾经告诉我他讨厌被盯着看，尤其是被男人。
Marlon Brando steps through the sliding glass door in a tropical terry cloth robe. Without a word, he drops himself on the couch next to me. Coughs, stretches out his bare, pallid legs and pans the room as if to root out anything unfamiliar. I can feel his eyes stop at me.
马龙·白兰度穿着一件热带毛巾布长袍穿过滑动玻璃门。他一言不发地把自己扔在我旁边的沙发上。咳嗽、伸出他那赤裸、苍白的腿，环视房间，好像要搜寻任何不熟悉的东西。我能感觉到他的目光停在我身上。
The editor asked Brando if he's ready to view the tapes. "What do you think?" asked Brando. The tapes start rolling with a closeup of Brando's still-handsome 77-year-old profile. I'm nervous that he hasn't yet acknowledged my presence. While still watching the tape, he sticks out his arm and extends a pinkie. It's a special Brando handshake. I respond and our pinkies entwine.
剪辑师问白兰度是否准备好看录像了。“你怎么看？”白兰度问。录像带开始滚动，特写镜头是他依然帅气的77岁侧脸。我很紧张，因为他还没承认我的存在。当看着录像带时，他伸出胳膊伸出一根小指。这是一个特殊的白兰度式握手。我回应了，我们的小指交缠在一起。
The first time he offered this handshake, I thought he was afraid I had germs. But I soon learned it was a sign of affection. I existed.
他第一次提出这种握手时，我还以为他怕我有细菌。但我很快意识到这是一种亲情的标志。我存在。
I met Brando when I was a teenager. I had dated his daughter Rebecca for about half an hour, but maintained a friendship. We were sitting in his den watching MTV when she said, "Turn it down, I think my dad's coming." "How do you know?" I asked. "I just do." I did notice that the tropical fish were no longer swimming, but idling.
我十几岁时认识了白兰度。我和他的女儿丽贝卡约会了大约半小时，但保持了友谊。我们坐在他的书房里看MTV时，她说，“调小点，我想我爸要来了。”“你怎么知道？”我问。“我就是知道。”我确实注意到热带鱼不再游动，而是处于待机状态。
The door creaked open. He sat down between us, mostly naked in a Japanese robe. I stared. I couldn't help it. It was Marlon Brando. After a few minutes of listening to him rip into MTV, he turned to me and said, "You know, you have a very wide antenna, a large antenna. Most people hide their antennas, but yours is very active, very open." What could I say but "thanks."
门吱呀一声开了。他坐在我们中间，大部分身体赤裸，穿着一件日本长袍。我盯着看。我忍不住。那是马龙·白兰度。听他猛烈抨击MTV几分钟后，他转向我说，“你知道，你有一个非常宽的天线，一个大天线。大多数人隐藏他们的天线，但你的非常活跃，非常开放。”我能说什么，只能说“谢谢”。
Only he wasn't through. "I'm not really sure, but my gut feeling is that you're a homosexual. Am I right?" I wasn't. But I found myself answering, "yes." He nodded and left the room.
他还没说完。“我不确定，但我的直觉告诉我你是个同性恋。对吗？”我不是。但我发现自己回答，“是的。”他点了点头，离开了房间。
The second time I met him, almost 10 years later, he offered me a job. He said he thought of me because I didn't seem to be overly neurotic. Thanks, I said. He said, "Now the job could involve things like building a dog house for my mastiff, Tim. Or I might walk up to you and ask you to take apart a radio and put it back together again. The job will have various benefits. Like trips to my house in Tahiti. I might ask you to mount a surveillance on the island. Or to run down to Casa Vega and pick up a dozen tacos."
我第二次见他，近10年后，他给我一份工作。他说他想到我，因为我看起来不是太神经质。谢谢，我说。他说，“现在这份工作可能涉及一些事情，比如为我的獒犬蒂姆建造一个狗屋。或者我可能会走过来，让你拆开一台收音机，再把它组装回去。这份工作会有各种福利。比如去我在塔希提岛的家旅行。我可能会让你对那个岛进行监视。或者跑去Casa Vega给我买一打玉米饼。”
Things went south after a month when Marlon's porno-watching Argentinian house man cornered me with a violent, pointing finger and said, "Marlon say you work for me now." I'd been demoted. It was an order that could only come from the top. What was once an exquisite paycheck for merely being myself had become a hackneyed, proletariat job of attrition. I was fired after a month when I refused to cut down all the sick, 40-foot high bamboo trees. They were loaded with bugs and I was, let's face it, just a dandy.
一个月后事情变坏了，当马龙那看色情电影的阿根廷男仆用暴力、指点的手指把我围住，说，“马龙说你现在为我工作。”我被降职了。这是一个只能来自高层的命令。曾经仅因做我自己就能获得的一份精致薪水，已经变成了一种陈词滥调的、无产阶级的消耗性工作。一个月后，当我拒绝砍掉所有那些有病的、40英尺高的竹子时，我被解雇了。它们载满了虫子，坦白说，我只是个花花公子。
Brando's memory runs short. In late 2001, he called me via one of his employees, and asked me if I'd be interested in writing an article about his new project on acting, Lying for a Living. Knowing full well that my last job with Brando was a fiasco, I deliberated. The next day I was laid off and the prospect became interesting. Besides, I was honored that he'd asked me, essentially a nobody. Actually, that's probably why he did ask me.
白兰度的记忆力很短。2001年末，他通过他的一名员工打电话给我，问我是否有兴趣写一篇关于他的新表演项目《以谎言为生》的文章。我很清楚我最后一份在白兰度那里的工作是场惨败，我犹豫了。第二天我被裁员了，这个前景变得有趣起来。此外，我很荣幸他竟然问我，一个基本上是无名小卒的人。其实，这可能就是他问我的原因。
Over lunch, I ask Brando why he decided to call his project Lying for a Living . He insists that the title isn't meant to be cute. If you can lie, he says, you can act. His intention is to turn out better liars onstage or off. Lying, he explains, is a social lubricant we can't live without.
午餐时，我问白兰度为什么决定把他的项目命名为《以谎言为生》。他坚持认为这个标题不是为了可爱。如果你能撒谎，他说，你就能表演。他的目的是培养舞台上或舞台下更好的骗子。撒谎，他解释说，是我们无法离开的社会润滑剂。
"I've been lying all my life," he tells me. "Everybody does." I ask him whether he thinks he's a good liar. "Jesus," he says. "I'm fabulous at it."
“我一生都在撒谎，”他告诉我。“每个人都这样做。”我问他是否认为自己是个好骗子。“天哪，”他说。“我非常擅长。”
The classes are a little weird. In the tapes, Brando, the master, sits at the head of the class in a massive leather armchair adorned like a throne. His two bare feet dangling languidly off an ottoman. A lamp with ram's horns flanks his right. A large, tropical plant stands behind him. Throw in the flamboyant pink scarf flung around his neck, and Brando looks like a frightening combination of Liberace and Freud.
课程有点奇怪。在录像带里，大师白兰度坐在教室前头的一个巨大的皮革扶手椅上，装饰得像王座。他那双赤裸的脚懒洋洋地垂在脚凳上。一个带有公羊角的台灯在他的右侧。一大棵热带植物站在他身后。再加上他脖子上随意甩着的浮夸粉色围巾，白兰度看起来就像利伯拉切和弗洛伊德的恐怖结合体。
The classes are, to say the least, star-studded. With Brando's guest list including the likes of Sean Penn, Jon Voight, Leonardo DiCaprio, Nick Nolte, Edward James Olmos, Robin Williams, Whoopi Goldberg, and even Michael Jackson, sitting among the dozen or so aspiring actors. It's interesting to see these familiar faces undirected and candid. Only Sean Penn looks bored throughout the tapes, smirking as if there's an inside joke to get. Everyone else, from Jon Voight to Nick Nolte looks utterly studious.
课程，至少可以说，星光熠熠。白兰度的客人名单包括西恩·潘、乔恩·沃伊特、莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥、尼克·诺尔蒂、爱德华·詹姆斯·奥尔莫斯、罗宾·威廉姆斯、乌比·戈德堡，甚至迈克尔·杰克逊，他们坐在十几名有抱负的演员中间。看到这些熟悉的面孔不做作、坦诚地展示是很有趣的。只有西恩·潘在录像带里看起来很无聊，窃笑仿佛有什么内部笑话。其他人，从乔恩·沃伊特到尼克·诺尔蒂，看起来都非常勤奋。
They have good reason. Brando hardly ever discusses his craft, and for the first time in years, he's talking about acting as if it matters. He talks a lot about being willing to make an ass of yourself. With this in mind, on the third day of class, he turns himself into a bosomy English woman. He saunters onto the sound stage wearing lipstick, blush, Chinese silk pajamas, and a cobalt blue scarf knotted coquettishly around his neck. A sultry makeup girls kneels at his feet, applying fire-red nail polish to his hands, while two students labor through an improv.
他们有充分的理由。白兰度几乎从不讨论他的技艺，这是多年来他第一次谈论表演，就好像它很重要一样。他谈了很多关于愿意让自己出丑的事情。考虑到这一点，在课的第三天，他把自己变成了丰满的英国妇女。他涂着口红，擦着胭脂，穿着中式丝绸睡衣，钴蓝色围巾在脖子上俏皮地打着结，昂首阔步地走上舞台。一个性感的化妆女孩跪在他的脚下，给他的手涂上火红的指甲油，而两名学生辛苦地进行着即兴表演。
"If you're not willing to fall on your face," he says. "If you're not willing to do something that's really stupid, embarrassing, then you're not going to do it." When I ask Brando why he's making the tapes, he says, "One word. Money." But watching him, it's clear that he's making an effort to be a good teacher. He's usually sensitive and positive with his students. Even when their improvs are bad. Like one in which a woman pretends to be a crazy person in a mental institution, talking in a little girl's voice for a good 20 minutes, he's supportive. His trademark comment after most scenes is "good, damn good."
“如果你不愿意摔倒在自己脸上，”他说。“如果你不愿意做一些真正愚蠢、令人尴尬的事情，那么你就不会去做它。”当我问白兰度为什么制作这些录像带时，他说，“一个词。钱。”但看着他，很明显他正在努力成为一名好老师。他通常对学生敏感且积极。即使他们的即兴表演很烂。就像其中一个，一个女人假装是精神病院的疯子，用小女孩的声音说话足足20分钟，他也很支持。他在大多数场景后的标志性评论是“好，该死的好”。
Of course, Brando's eccentricities do show up on the tapes. Like when he declares he wants to sing the actor's national anthem, and then puts his hand over his heart and sings, "Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me. You." Or when he asks a very beautiful female student-- a competitive runner and model, despite having lost her legs-- to come to the front of the class and tell her story of healing and accomplishment. The high point of her story comes when she says she realized that she could run faster if she fashioned her prosthetic limbs after those of a cheetah. Perhaps this wouldn't be so strange if Brando weren't sitting behind her on his throne, totally poker faced, like the facilitator of an AA meeting. After her story, as she returns to her chair, Brando chimes in. "And she looks pretty good going away."
当然，白兰度的怪癖确实出现在了录像带上。比如当他宣布想唱演员的国歌，然后把手放在胸口唱，“我，我，我，我，我，我，我，我。你。”或者当他问一位非常美丽的女学生——一位竞争激烈的跑步者和模特，尽管失去了双腿——走到教室前，讲述她康复和成就的故事。她故事的高潮是当她说她意识到如果她把假肢做成猎豹的样子，她就能跑得更快。如果白兰度不是坐在她后面的王座上，完全面无表情，就像酗酒者匿名互助会会议的主持人一样，这也许就不会那么奇怪了。故事讲完后，当她回到椅子上时，白兰度插话说。“而且她离开时的样子看起来相当不错。”
Occasionally the tapes show Brando with a coger's unwitting political naivete. Ironic for a man once known as a staunch activist for Native Americans and other causes. On the first day of class he proudly introduces a man he found rummaging through the dumpsters outside, and recruited to join the class. A special surprise, he calls it. The camera swirls to Jim, a bearded black man looking cleaned up and nervous. "Jim was outside here, monkeying with the trash containers. What do you do, Jim?" Brando ask. "Recycling," he says.
偶尔录像带会显示出白兰度作为老头子不经意的政治天真。对于一个曾经以美洲原住民和其他事业的坚定活动家而闻名的人来说，这很讽刺。课的第一天，他自豪地介绍了一个他在外面翻垃圾箱时发现的男人，并招募他加入课堂。一个特殊的惊喜，他称之为。摄像机转向吉姆，一个留着胡子的黑人，看起来洗干净了，很紧张。“吉姆在外面，摆弄垃圾箱。你是做什么的，吉姆？”白兰度问。“回收，”他说。
On day 14, Brando has two dwarfs and a giant Samoan do an improv. At one point, the dwarfs start punching each other and the Samoan separates them like two unleashed puppies. At the end of the scene, Brando lavishly praises the performance. "When something's good, it hits you. I get chicken skin when something's really right." There may be a remote chance that someone in the class was engaged with the improv. But to the viewer, the scene comes off as nothing more than a bad bar joke.
第14天，白兰度让两个侏儒和一个巨人萨摩亚人做即兴表演。在某一刻，侏儒开始互相打拳，萨摩亚人像分开两只失控的小狗一样分开他们。场景结束时，白兰度大加赞赏表演。“当某事很好时，它会击中你。当某事真正对时，我会起鸡皮疙瘩。”班里的人可能有人投入了即兴表演的远程机会。但对观众来说，这个场景不过是个糟糕的酒吧笑话。
Brando wants to be a good teacher, but what the tapes prove is that he simply doesn't have a clue how. I think that acting comes so naturally to him that he doesn't know how he does it. Brando assumes that because everyone lies, everyone can act.
白兰度想成为一名好老师，但录像带证明他根本不知道怎么做。我认为表演对他来说太自然了，以至于他不知道自己是怎么做到的。白兰度假设因为每个人都会撒谎，所以每个人都能表演。
In one of the tapes, he explains how he created the character of Don Corleone for The Godfather . He'd never played an Italian, he says, and he was scared of doing the part with big Italian gestures. So he put some cotton into his cheeks and imitated an Italian he knew, producer Dino De Laurentiis, who, according to Brando, took a shot in the throat and had that raspy, whispery voice. From the voice apparently came the rest of the character.
在其中一盘录像带中，他解释了如何为《教父》创造唐·柯里昂这个角色。他说他从来没演过意大利人，他很害怕用夸张的意大利姿势来演这个角色。所以他往脸颊里塞了一些棉花，模仿了他认识的一个意大利人，制片人迪诺·德·劳伦蒂斯，他据白兰度所说，喉咙中过枪，有那种沙哑、耳语般的声音。角色剩下的部分显然来自这个声音。
It's an interesting story. But if you were a young actor wanting to create a personality on screen as complicated and compelling as Brando's character in The Godfather , it wouldn't help you very much. All the things that make his performance great, he doesn't say anything about. I don't think he'd be able to, even if he wanted. Even if you paid him, which he hopes you will.
这是一个有趣的故事。但如果你是一个年轻演员，想在银幕上创造一个像《教父》中白兰度角色那样复杂且引人注目的个性，它对你帮助不大。所有使他表演伟大的东西，他什么也没说。我不认为他能做到，即使他想。即使你付钱给他，这是他希望你会做的。
Two weeks later, we're watching the tapes in Brando's office. "I look like Grandma Moses," jokes Brando. "Can you crop it? Jesus, I look pregnant." The next thing I know, Brando's hand is groping my knee. It's not a sexual advance, but a curious one, as if you were examining a rottweiler for purchase. "You've got big, strong legs," he says. The footage continues, and I feel his hand move on to my humble bicep. "You're solid, man."
两周后，我们在白兰度的办公室里看录像带。“我看起来像摩西奶奶，”白兰度开玩笑说。“你能裁剪一下吗？天哪，我看起来像怀孕了。”下一刻，白兰度的手在摸我的膝盖。这不是性挑逗，而是一种好奇，就像你在检查一只罗威纳犬是否值得购买一样。“你有大而强壮的腿，”他说。镜头继续，我感觉到他的手移动到我卑微的二头肌上。“你很结实，伙计。”
At that point, the camera shows DiCaprio improvising on a phone. "He looks like a girl," says Brando. It's possible that none of this footage will ever be released. The videos are supposed to come out in the fall, but a certain amount of chaos has surrounded the whole production from the start. He scrutinizes the screen and then asks, to no one in particular, "Who wants to see a fat, 80-year-old man pontificate?"
在那一刻，摄像机显示迪卡普里奥在电话上即兴表演。“他看起来像个女孩，”白兰度说。这些镜头很可能永远不会发布。录像带应该在秋季出来，但整个制作过程从一开始就伴随着一定程度的混乱。他仔细审视屏幕，然后对不知名的某人问，“谁想看一个肥胖的80岁老人夸夸其谈？”
Jod Kaftan. A version of his story appeared in Rolling Stone.
乔德·卡夫坦。他的故事版本出现在《滚石》杂志上。
Our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer, Julie Snyder.
我们的节目今天由温迪·多尔和我制作，艾利克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩参与。高级制片人，朱莉·斯奈德。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
【鸣谢】
Our story on recovered memory was part of a series called The America Project , which gets funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
我们关于恢复记忆的故事是名为“美国项目”系列的一部分，该系列获得了公共广播公司（CPB）的资助。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Funding for our show comes from the listeners of WBEZ Chicago.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我们节目的资助来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的听众。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who explained my job to me this way back when I was hired--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，当我在那时候受聘时，他这样向我解释我的工作——
Now the job could involve things like building a doghouse for my mastiff, Tim. Or I might walk up to you, and ask  you to take apart a radio and put it back together.
现在这份工作可能涉及一些事情，比如为我的獒犬蒂姆建造一个狗屋。或者我可能会走过来，让你拆开一台收音机，再把它组装回去。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Marlon say you work for me now.
马龙说你现在为我工作。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。